-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite mom quotes
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one
is from @Martycheddar.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @Rachelle1101.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's a hoot.
OTAH.
-OTAH.
Oh, that is a hoot.
[ Laughter ]
-That's two hoots.
-That's a toodle.
Toodles.
OTAH.
I think that can catch on.
That's good.
This one is from @alainagendron.
She says...
-Oh!
[ Applause ]
-That's a pretty good bit.
-How rude of you!
-This next one's from @mistyfox.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
You take a Goober home again?
[ Goober voice ]
Yeah, I guess I did.
[ Normal voice ]
This one's from @kaitbly17.
She says...
Play Boy. Game Boy.
Ah, whatever.
-Oh, that's a hoot.
[ Laughter ]
-He just plays it
for the articles.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughs ]
-This one's from
@Madisonbellis10.
She says...
-Yeah!
-Whoa.
-Wow.
Boing!
[ Bass drum hit ]
[ Cymbal hit ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Drum hit ]
This one's from @NateHoot.
-That's a hoot.
-Oh, that's a hoot.
[ Laughter ]
That's a real hoot.
OTAH.
-OTAH to the max.
-OTAH.
-Haters gonna hate.
Hooters gonna hoot.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-What? Get out of here. Go.
Just go. Just go.
[ Blues music plays ]
Steve Higgins.
There he goes.
Get out of here.
Love you, buddy.
I love you, man.
Love you.
Steve Higgins, everybody.
Steve Higgins.
Three years in the business.
[ Music ends ]
Uh, hey.
You're back.
-Yeah.
-What happened?
-Not a hoot out there.
-Oh, yeah.
This one is from @NateHoot.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No, I'm your son.
I not gonna try
to destroy your --
What?
[ Laughs ]
I'm purposely trying to destroy
your computer, Mom.
Gosh. Parents just don't
understand computers.
Am I gonna be like this?
-Yeah.
Something with the glob-glib.
You don't even know what it is.
Hasn't been invented.
-Yeah. I try to FaceTime
with my family...
-Dad, you got a bleep-bloop.
-...and my mom and dad,
they don't understand.
They don't know where
the camera's aimed.
It's going up their nose,
and I hear, "What?
Where are you?
What?
I can't see me."
I go, "You're not supposed to.
We're not gonna worry about you.
Look at the kids."
[ Sighs ]
"Where are -- Where am I?"
Where are you?
No, you're home.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm taping cardboard
over the camera
'cause they can see you."
No one's trying
to spy on you, Dad.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, they could take
my secret recipe."
Yeah, right.
[ Laughter ]
No one's breaking
into your hard drive.
Please.
This one's from @PeachesK1974.
She says...
Oh, that's pretty good.
-Come on.
-Not bad.
How's Jovi Bon Jovi?
-This one's from
@TheLordHasSpoke.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's hard to ignore
those tweets.
-Fanta-- [ Laughs ]
He says...
Hey.
Absolute.
I love it.
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
Box wine, man.
Nothing wrong with it, man.
-A refrigerator box.
-Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
This one's from @Zwackinator.
-Zwackinator?
-Wasn't that your nickname
in college?
-It was,
but that was before Twitter.
[ Laughter ]
-How many steps you have
on your Fitbit?
[ Laughter ]
-Like 30,000.
-43,000.
-30,000 when I'm wearing it
on my right hand.
-You haven't left the room,
and you have 30,000 steps.
-On my left hand, none --
like, zero.
[ Laughter ]
[ Blues music plays ]
There he is.
Get out of here.
Take off. I love you, man.
♪♪
Steve Higgins, everybody.
Here we go.
We're down to our last one.
It's our last one here,
everybody.
This one is from @Brigreenspan.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
There you have it.
Those are
"'Tonight Show' Hashtags."
Happy Mother's Day, moms!
Check out more of our favorites.
Go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.